ستبقى روسيه للابد تعهد قطعه فلاديمير
بوتين عام 2014 عند ضم شبه جزيره القرم
وانتزاعها من الخريطه الاوكرانيه غير ان
انفجارات وغارات جويه عده اظهرت وفق اعلام
غربيه هشاشه الوجود الروسي هناك كما ابرزت
شبه الجزيره كجزء من اهداف اوكرانيا في
هذه الحرب للتغلب على الرعب من الضروري ان
ننتصر في المعركه ضد العدوان الروسي وان
نحرر القرم
الضربات الاوكرانيه في عمق شبه جزيره
القرم ومن ضمنها استهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبل هدفها
استنزاف اللوجستيات ومراكز القياده
والسيطره اي تعطيل خطوط الامداد الروسيه
اولا كما تهدف لعرقله توغل موسكو جنوبي
اوكرانيا ومخططها البرمائي للاندفاع غربا
باتجاه اوداسا وانشاء جسر بري الى مولدوفا
الا ان الضربه الكبرى تمثلت بالانفجار
الذي هز جسر الحيوي في اكتوبر 2022 ما ادى
لتدمير جزء منه وتعطيل حركه النقل وان
لفتره هذا الجسر هو الاطول في اوروبا
ويمتد لتسعه عشر كيلو مترا بلغت تكلفه
تشييده ثلاثه مليارات وسته مئه مليون
دولار ويعد حلقه وصل بين شبه جزيره القرم
ومنطقه كريسنو دارك راي الروسيه شمالي
القوقاز نائب رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي
وصفاح حينها الانفجار بمثابه اعلان حرب في
معدته الخارجيه الروسيه دليلا على ما
وصفته الطبيعه الارهابيه للحكومه
الاوكرانيه اما مستشار زيلنسكي فاكد ان
الانفجار مجرد بدايه طالما ان كل شيء غير
شرعي يجب تدميره وفق تعبيره
الضربات الاوكرانيه في شبه الجزيره جاءت
متقطعه على مدى اشهر الا ان وثيرتها
ازدادت بشكل كبير خلال الايام الاخيره وهي
وفق الوصف الروسيه تعتبر اعمالا ارهابيه
وتخريبيه يسعى لتفكيك شبكه منفذها لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات